[Music]
[Applause]
welcome this for Jesus Christ
I didn't back it off uh welcome to Smart
Castle Cinemas kids I'm your host Uh
Kevin Smith and it is if I'm correct my
and my phone is correct Friday the
[__] 13th put your hands together we
survived
Friday the 13th
but I did I used to go over to Ernie's
house and watch
um he had cable so that's where we first
watched like the first two Friday the
13th I think we watched like at a resist
and then from three forward I got to see
him uh in theaters
um this flick ladies and gentlemen has a
you know chunk of Cinema history in as
much as it was shot here in the great
state of New Jersey they shot the first
Five Thirteen yes
local Pride man nothing is better than
the interactive Movie experience for a
film that you've seen I would argue of
course that like you know if we were
watching Ant-Man for the first time I'd
be like everybody shut the [__] up like
nobody cheered nobody say a [__] word
because I ain't gonna miss a goddamn
Easter egg because of you people you
know but since we've seen these movies
in particular Batman and now this
probably many times and stuff I would
encourage you man makes it so much more
fun every time somebody gets killed
[__] scream your head off as if it's
the greatest thing that ever happened
man just Hoot and Holler and [__]
cheer for it it makes it a so much more
fun and B you start being real
suspicious of everybody around you
because they're all cheering death a
little too [__] loudly so let's watch
Friday the 13th I'll see you in a bit
foreign
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]